ça va tout le monde est là
bien mes chers collègues
nous voici réunis ce matin pour entendre
la secrétaire d'État aux Affaires
européennes nous rendre compte de la
dernière réunion du Conseil européen des
20 et 21 octobre dernier madame la
ministre je vous remercie de votre
présence ce matin naturellement la
guerre en Ukraine est restée au cœur des
préoccupations des chefs d'État ou de
gouvernement dans un contexte d'escalade
de conf marqué par de nouvelles
annexions illégales et des attaques
aveugles de la Russie par missile et
drone envers les infrastructures civiles
de l'Ukraine le Conseil européen
confirmé sa volonté de soutenir
l'Ukraine au si longtemps que nécessaire
au plan politique bien sûr militaire et
financier via l'assistance
macro-financière il a aussi demandé à la
Commission de concevoir une solution
plus structurelle or au sommet qui s'est
tenu hier à Berlin pour parler
reconstruction de l'Ukraine la
présidente wanderleyen a d'ores et déjà
promis une aide nouvelle de 1,5
milliards d'euros à l'Ukraine en 2023
pouvez-vous nous en dire plus
s'agira-t-il de près ou de dons comment
lier ces investissements aux réformes
nécessaires en vue de l'entrée de
l'Ukraine dans l'Union
deuxième sujet du Conseil européen
étroitement corrélé au premier la crise
énergétique
le niveau compte atteint les prix de
l'énergie n'est plus tenable ni pour les
ménages ni pour les entreprises lors de
la Table Ronde que notre commission
organisée sur le sujet il y a deux
semaines un chercheur a évalué à 10% la
part de notre industrie et nergot
intensive qui aurait déjà été détruite
selon lui chaque mois qui passe augmente
d'un point ce pourcentage de destruction
face à cette urgence le Conseil européen
n'a pourtant pas réussi à s'accorder sur
des solutions suffisantes pour éviter de
fermer définitivement un certain nombre
d'industries madame la ministre alors
que l'Allemagne joue cavalier seul et
annonce un plan de 200 milliards d'euros
croyez-vous possible de parvenir à une
réponse européenne solidaire à l'urgence
énergétique
si oui dans combien de temps parce que
là aussi on a vu quelques
tergiversations sur la temporalité entre
le Président de la République et
certains ministres
comment la France entend-t-elle obtenir
l'extension au niveau européen du
mécanisme
ibérique l'annonce par le Président de
la République à l'ouverture du Conseil
européen un projet de gazoduction marin
barmar entre Barcelone et Marseille la
visiblement pas à Madou et l'Allemagne
au-delà des controverses en cours sur la
passe difficile que traverse la relation
franco-allemande donc quelle mesure la
rencontre intervenue hier entre le
chancelier scholls et le président
Macron permet-elle d'espérer sortir de
l'impasse madame la ministre je vous
laisse la parole bien sûr pour répondre
à ces quelques questions mais aussi pour
nous donner votre point de vue de bilan
de ce conseil merci
merci merci monsieur le Président
Madame la vice-présidente monsieur le
vice-président monsieur le rapporteur
général mesdames les sénatrices et
messieurs les sénateurs
d'abord je vous remercie pour cette
invitation à vous présenter les
résultats du Conseil européen qui a
réuni nos chefs d'État et de
gouvernement Judy et vendredi dernier
et personnellement je suis ravie de vous
retrouver deux semaines après vous avoir
expliqué les enjeux de ce conseil afin
de revenir sur les principaux sujets qui
ont été traités le résultat des
discussions et vous en avez cité
quelques-uns monsieur le président
alors il y avait d'abord un point de
calendrier que j'avais souligné lors de
notre dernière
échange comme vous savez la
présidentielle a réuni deux fois en 15
jours les chefs d'État et de
gouvernement et c'est précisément parce
qu'on a ces trois chocs majeurs que vous
avez évoqué l'agression de l'Ukraine par
la Russie la crise énergétique et puis
il y a également la crise alimentaire et
sur les trois ils ont discuté
évidemment on nous attendons est-ce
qu'il y en est d'autres l'actualité la
plus récente confirme la nécessité
d'échanges au plus haut niveau répété la
guerre initiée par la Russie contre
l'Ukraine continue de faire rage et
c'est un des éléments essentiels de ce
Conseil européen que d'avoir continué à
affirmer le soutien à l'Ukraine y
compris et ça c'est nouveau par la prise
en compte d'acteurs comme l'Iran où on
souhaite encore aux problématiques comme
la sécurité alimentaire ou la lutte
contre l'impunité
et bien sûr il y a eu la question
d'énergie et j'y reviendrai mais ce sont
ajoutés de nouveaux sujets après les
développements récents par exemple
comment mieux protéger nos
infrastructures critiques après les
attaques entre les gazeux du Nord Stream
également évolution de la relation avec
la Chine et puis la préparation des
sciences internationales comme le sommet
de la cop27 et le sommet entre Union
européenne et l'Asia
alors sur sur l'Ukraine
évidemment le Conseil a condamné avec la
plus grande fermeté les récentes
attaques de missiles et de drones qui
ont été perpétrées sans discrimination
contre des fibres entre les biens des
infrastructures civiles à Kiev dans
toute l'Ukraine le président de la
République l'a dit pendant la conférence
de presse c'est vraiment une stratégie
russe pour détruire méthodiquement les
capacités de résistance et les
infrastructures civiles essentielles
pour l'hiver en Ukraine
et dans ce contexte les chefs d'État est
gouvernement l'Union européenne bien sûr
vont maintenir la pression sur le régime
russe pour continuer de l'affaiblir
durablement avec l'objectif clair que
nous avons discuté plusieurs fois ici
qui est d'asphyxier l'effort de guerre
russes
ce qui est nouveau c'est que les mesures
restrictives maintenant s'étendent aux
alliés du Kremlin dans cette guerre
par exemple il y a eu des sanctions
prises en réaction au transfert de
drones iranien à la Russie et puis le
Conseil s'est dit prêt à adopter de
nouvelles mesures à l'encontre de la
Biélorussie puisque celle-ci a
considérablement renforcé son soutien
militaire à la Russie
alors il y a trois plans en particulier
sur lesquels je voudrais insister sur ce
soutien à l'Ukraine le premier c'est le
plan humanitaire
le Conseil enfin l'Union européenne
soutiendra au côté de l'Ukraine en
particulier en vue de la préparation à
l'hiver sur le plan militaire comme vous
savez il y a eu ces dernières semaines
le lancement d'une mission européenne de
formation de soldats ukrainien à
laquelle la France prend une grande part
et puis nous avons également décidé de
renforcer les mesures d'assistance au
titre de la facilité européenne pour la
paix afin de soutenir les forces armées
ukrainiennes
sur le plan financier et de façon plus
immédiate les dirigeants européens
continuent de soutenir
leurs efforts avec la poursuite du
décaissement rapide de la deuxième
tranche de l'aide macro-financière à
l'Ukraine c'est un milliards d'euros et
il travaille à la mise à disposition des
trois milliards restants
et en fin deux autres choses sur le plan
politique
je crois qu'on s'était vu mais néanmoins
le comme vous savez il y a eu le premier
sommet de la communauté politique
européenne ou CPE a Prague au niveau des
chefs d'État et gouvernement qui a été
un succès la deuxième SCPE se tiendra en
Moldavie au printemps 2023 et là on
passera d'une coopération plus poétique
à des coopérations plus concrètes
enfin sur le plan juridique il y a eu
des discussions sur
sur les poursuites qui auraient lieu à
la suite de la guerre et l'Union
européenne a rappelé son engagement dans
la lutte contre l'impunité pour les
crimes de guerre et les crimes contre
l'humanité il y a des
évidemment des violations évidentes du
droit international elles doivent être
sanctionnées et surtout les outils
doivent
permettre de sanctionner tous les
dirigeants quel que soit leur niveau qui
ont pris part dans cette guerre
ensuite comme vous le savez mardi il y a
eu la conférence pour la reconstruction
de l'Ukraine à laquelle l'Union
européenne lors du Conseil a rappelé son
plein soutien en lien avec les
institutions financières mondiales qui
seront mobilisés
et puis il y a eu tout un volant de
discussion sur la lutte contre la
désinformation afin de réduire en ou de
soutenir plutôt les efforts collectifs
pour des fins
et l'ordre international fondé sur les
règles il s'agit bien évidemment ici de
rappeler que c'est la Russie qui est
responsable des crises énergétiques et
économiques qui nous touche
le Conseil a aussi discuté de la
sécurité de l'insécurité alimentaire
mondiale qui est causée par la guerre à
nouveau en rappelant et je crois que
c'est important de répéter
la responsabilité russe dans la crise
alimentaire mondiale donc le Conseil a
souligner la nécessité du renforcement
des corridors de solidarité ils ont déjà
permis de faire sortir plus de 10
millions de tonnes de céréales d'Ukraine
et puis c'était aussi l'occasion de
rappeler l'initiative farm portée par le
Président de la République et son
déploiement en européen en lien avec
l'Union africaine
monsieur le Président vous m'avez
interrogé sur la crise énergétique qui
est plutôt les réponses qui sont
apportées
j'ai évidemment le sujet qui a pris le
plus de temps de discussions entre les
chefs d'État et de gouvernement
lors du Conseil les chefs d'états et des
gouvernements sont revenus sur les
propositions de la Commission européenne
communiquer le 18 octobre qui complète
des règlements déjà adoptés pour les
mesures d'urgence ces règlements
concernent la réduction de la
consommation d'énergie la contribution
des entreprises énergétiques le
renforcement de notre stockage de gaz ou
encore la diversification de nos
approvisionnements
la Commission à la demande des États
membres a fait de nouvelles propositions
qui devrait permettre notamment la mise
en place de la plateforme d'achat
conjoint à l'échelle de l'Union
européenne
et les pays membres de la communauté de
l'énergie c'est important parce que ça
nous donne un vrai pouvoir de marché
dans les négociations avec les
fournisseurs d'énergie de gaz notamment
et ça va nous permettre ça devrait nous
aider à remplir nos stocks de gaz à des
prix plus raisonnables en vue de l'hiver
prochain
il y a également de nouvelles
propositions pour faciliter la
conclusion d'accord de solidarité entre
État membre et puis tout un pan d'autres
mesures sur lesquelles je reviendrai
pendant les questions mais les chefs
d'État et gouvernement ont en fait
chargé la commission d'explorer
notamment le cas mécanisme ubérique
auquel vous faisiez allusion
un corridor de prix ou bien le
plafonnement des prix du gaz qui sont
utilisés pour produire de l'électricité
et tout ça n'affecte pas les pays et les
27 pays de l'Union européenne de la même
façon le Conseil énergique a eu lieu
mardi 25 octobre a permis notamment
d'échanger à nouveau au niveau politique
sur ce sujet la commission
if a fait des propositions sur certaines
aspects notamment la mise en place de la
plateforme et l'évolution d'indice de
prix du gaz et la présidence tchèque a
déjà annoncé qu'elle visait une adoption
dès le 24 novembre au cours d'un nouveau
conseil énergie de certaines de ces
mesures
vous pouvez parfois trouver que ça prend
un peu de temps mais je crois qu'il est
important de dire que beaucoup de choses
ont été réalisées quand même en très peu
de temps sur des sujets très techniques
et sur la base de politique énergétique
des membres de façon individuels qui
sont très différents d'un pays à l'autre
comme vous savez donc nous nous
attendons de la commission qu'elle fasse
de nouvelles propositions notamment sur
les découplages de l'électricité et
celui du gaz comme vous savez c'est
quelque chose qui est fortement porté
partout les ministres du gouvernement
vous le savez aussi la Russie poursuit
bien sûr
l'instrumentalisation de
l'approvisionnement énergétique de
l'Union en réduisant continuellement les
livraisons de gaz elle n'est pas un
partenaire ni un fournisseur fiable et
la situation nous elle n'a pas changé
mais nous ne sommes pas qu'elle va
changer dans le court terme donc nos
relations énergétiques ne seront plus
jamais les mêmes avec le Kremlin mais
avec aussi d'autres partenaires et c'est
pourquoi que nous poursuivons deux
projets supplémentaires complémentaires
le premier qui est de continuer de
réduire la dépendance à l'égard de la
Russie et le deuxième le côté noir
réduire notre dépendance à l'égard des
énergies fossiles et c'est pour ça que
le
que nous essayons vraiment de garder une
cohérence entre les mesures qui sont
prises en urgence au niveau européen et
puis la trajectoire énergétique et
climatique de l'Union européenne et donc
nous pourrions avoir très prochainement
des dispositions pour construire plus
rapidement des capacités d'énergie
renouvelables notamment en réduisant les
délais de procédure
et puis
et ce sera le dernier point pour
l'énergie le Conseil européen a rappelé
sa volonté d'une réforme structurelle
structurelle des marchés d'énergie pour
parvenir à un marché plus cohérent moins
volatile et pour cela les chefs d'État
avec Vernon attendent des propositions
de la Commission d'ici la fin de l'année
pour pouvoir commencer à avancer sur ce
sujet dès le début de 2023
ensuite sur les questions économiques
puisque vous m'avez posé monsieur le
Président la question en fait de la
fragmentation du marché intérieur de
façon indirecte et c'est vrai que ce
sont des sujets qui ont été soulevés au
Conseil européen
d'abord je crois qu'il nous faut
rappeler que la France grâce au Musée
National qu'elle a adopté à l'inflation
la plus basse de tous les États de la
zone euro je le répète parce que c'est
important dans une période où on parle
de salaire pouvoir d'achat et de
retraite
je vous rappellerai pas toutes les
mesures qui ont été prises où ils
avaient entendu hier soir de nouveau il
s'est évidemment le cas que nos
partenaires européens ont adopté
également des mesures similaires
ce sur quoi les chefs gouvernement
échangés c'est comment adopter des
mesures de protection nationale sans
introduire de distorsion dans le marché
intérieur des distorsions de concurrence
entre les États membres
et donc ils ont réaffirmé la nécessité
de mettre en place un cadre commun qui
pourrait également non seulement
conduire les dispositions nationales
mais aussi permettre une solidarité
financière avec ceux qui n'ont pas les
moyens comme l'Allemagne ou la France
c'est de faire des boucliers aussi
importants dans ce sens la Commission a
présenté une révision de l'encadrement
temporaire des crises pour les aides
d'État pour qu'on puisse soutenir nos
entreprises de façon
similaire ou en tous les cas c'est un
distorsion de concurrence et puis les
chefs d'État et de gouvernement se sont
penchés sur la possibilité d'une
nouvelle action économique commune au
niveau européen puisque comme je le
disais tous les États membres n'ont pas
la même les mêmes marges de manoeuvre
c'est d'ailleurs déjà le sens de la
proposition que la Commission étudiant
en ce moment et power you enfin qui est
plutôt dans les trilogues en ce moment
pardon donc il pourrait y avoir il y a
une phrase dans les communiqués du
Conseil européen de nouvelles
propositions pour que la part des
subventions de ce paquet financier soit
augmentée et puis les 27 ont donné
mandat à la Commission et au ministre
des Finances pour avancer sur des
mécanismes européens de solidarité
financière
ils sont également
convenu de la nécessité mais ça c'est un
peu à certains de mer vous l'avez déjà
entendu de réviser le modèle de
gouvernance économique et la Commission
européenne devait présenter le 9
novembre ces recommandations en ce sens
notamment pour le bac de stabilité et de
croissance et évidemment vous êtes en
nous ces propositions
enfin et c'est la dernière partie du
Conseil européen
les relations extérieures et notamment
les relations entre l'Union européenne
et la Chine
vous savez que l'Union européenne avait
défini son approche de relation avec la
Chine en 2019 autour du triptyque
partenariat coopération et rivalité
systémique
le Conseil européen a réaffirmé la
persistance du triptyque tout en tenant
compte de l'évolution du comportement de
la Chine c'est de dernière année et
évidemment cela donne un poids un peu
plus grand à la notion de rivalité
systémique dans les triptyque y compris
sur le plan des valeurs
du coup la réponse européenne va
s'adapter au changement structurel qui
se manifeste dans les relations entre
l'Union européenne et la Chine qu'il
s'agisse de la position chinoise sur la
guerre en Ukraine ou bien de la montée
des tensions dans le détraque Taïwan
ce qui veut dire en pratique que l'Union
européenne va continuer ses efforts pour
rééquilibrer la relation économique va
mettre en pardon en oeuvre davantage de
réciprocité par renforcer ses outils de
défense commerciaux pour suivre la
diversification des chaînes
d'approvisionnement en fait tout faire
pour limiter nos vulnérabilités
vis-à-vis de la Chine et il y a eu un
vrai consensus je crois en faveur d'une
autonomie stratégique européenne et ce
qui valide les positions françaises sur
la question évidemment nous allons
poursuivre maintenant la mise en œuvre
de l'agenda de Versailles
néanmoins c'est une position plus
mesurée que celle des États-Unis puisque
il y a des domaines dans lesquels il
faut évidemment nous ne pourrons pas
faire sans la Chine par exemple sur la
lutte contre le changement climatique ou
la protection de la biodiversité ou
enfin la sécurité alimentaire et la
santé et la santé mondiale
l'Europe a également
réaffirmer ça position très ferme sur la
valeur sur les défenses sur la défense
des valeurs et des droits de l'homme il
y a la publication de la proposition de
règlement de la Commission relative à
l'interdiction des produits issus du
travail forcé sur le marché de l'Union
et ça c'est une référence dans toutes
les discussions internationales sur le
sujet en plus de ce que nous affirmons
nous enfin le Conseil européen a est
revenu sur les grandes échéances
internationales je le mentionnais en
introduction la préparation de la cop21
qui est comme vous le savez a lieu du 6
au 18 novembre à Sharm-el-Sheikh
là le oui
le ministre de pardon l'environnement
ont adopté à l'unanimité lors du Conseil
Environnement du 24 octobre
de négociation de l'Union européenne
plus ambitieux pour la COP 27 et ça
refait bien la forte priorité française
pour une action climatique importante
ils ont également évoqué la préparation
du sommet entre l'Union européenne et
laséane qui aura lieu en décembre
prochain vous connaissez l'aziane si cet
espace stratégique en Asie du Sud-Est
qui occupe une place centrale pour nous
dans la stratégie adopacifique et ça
sera bien évidemment l'occasion de
mettre en valeur des réalisations
concrètes à ce sujet
vous l'avez vu c'était un Conseil
européen chargé nous avons un agenda qui
reste important pour les semaines et les
mois à venir mais nous avons sont
partout dans tous ces domaines et là et
nous avons aussi pour renforcer la
capacité d'action de l'Union je vous
remercie monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs
merci Madame la Ministre l'Union
européenne fait feu de tout bois on le
voit en ce moment sur beaucoup de sujets
hier j'ai
eu le plaisir de rencontrer nos
chefs de services ou directeur influents
au niveau des institutions européennes
et on a pu balayer un certain nombre de
sujets et
comprendre que et aujourd'hui
un travail très très important mené par
les institutions puisque tous les sujets
s'offrent à nous et sont devant nous
avec des sujets quand même conséquents
et les conséquences qu'entraînent
certains sujets je pense notamment à la
guerre en Ukraine j'ouvre le débat alors
il y avait Jacques ferrique d'abord
André ensuite André renfort
on y va
tout le monde lève la main
vas-y Jacques on va prendre les
questions par 3 si vous voulez madame
vous répondez pas soyez bref
il y a une audition après
oui donc
assurément la
réponse européenne commune globale
adaptée lisible par nos citoyens nos
entreprises nos collectivités etc de
réponse à la crise énergétique et elle
est pas encore là elle est pas encore
posée
vous l'avez dit ça prend un peu de temps
il y a pas les mêmes marges de manœuvre
entre États membres situations très
différentes d'un pays à l'autre
le mécanisme solidarité est annoncé
enfin on a quand même l'impression que
ça coin sérieusement que ça patine c'est
c'est pas la même ambiance que celle
qu'on a connu
face à la crise du covid par exemple
et donc les désaccords pattants et des
dépassements qui tarde à arriver des
dépassements de ces accords pour autant
qu'ils arrivent un jour je m'inquiète
notamment que vous avez bien rappelé
vous avez eu raison la nécessité à la
fois de réduire l'indépendance à l'égard
de la Russie mais aussi à des énergies
fossiles donc pas lâché nos objectifs
climats le Green Deal
à la faveur de la crise et sur ce
deuxième impératif il me semble en
danger maltenu au moment où on s'apprête
à faire une entorse majeure en Europe ou
principe de non financement européen des
infrastructures des énergies fossiles
donc il semble donc la France maintenant
avec l'Espagne et le Portugal je crois
soutien désormais le projet de gazoduc
sous la Méditerranée donc par Mars
se substituant au projet 4 qui a des
faveurs notamment de l'Allemagne j'avoue
que je comprends mal la cohérence entre
l'opposition juste de notre gouvernement
1004 donc une infrastructure qui
m'intéresse pour longtemps la dépendance
et la vulnérabilité offensile et il
soutient gazoduc sous-marin qui
reviendrait à peu près au même avec des
impacts lourds sur la biodiversité donc
on change le nom et le tracé mais
l'objectif reste le même
d'accord alors suivant André Richard
merci président madame la ministre un
ministre vous avez je crois l'utiliser
deux fois le l'expression ça va prendre
un certain temps ça prend un certain
temps pour les plus anciens on se
souvient du sketch de Fernand Raynaud et
le fût du canon ça va prendre un certain
temps vous connaissez vraiment la
pression qui est mise à l'heure actuelle
et sur les différents acteurs de la vie
civile en France cette crise énergétique
est en train progressivement d'étouffer
ça a été fort justement dit par le
président tout à l'heure d'étouffer
notre tissu économique on a commencé par
l'industrie maintenant c'est les petites
et moyennes entreprises c'est les
agriculteurs ça va s'arrêter où donc
malheureusement
ce conseil a envoyé à la commission un
certain nombre de propositions si je
peux me permettre ces propositions elle
devrait déjà être là devrait déjà être
là et comme l'a dit fort justement un
instant l'orateur précédent Jacques
ferrique
ça ça paraît indépendamment du discours
ça pas l'air d'aller dans le bon sens
rapidement voilà donc mon discours mon
ma question c'est est-ce que vous pouvez
nous préciser ce calendrier je vous
remercie
très bien
André merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre de points vous avez évoqué
la facilité européenne de paix on en
parle très peu on explique mal les
mécanismes ça fond qui a été créé en
mars 2021 de thé d'un peu moins de 5,7
milliards il est utilisé abondamment
pour compenser un certain nombre d'aides
militaires financièrement fait par les
pays de l'Union au passage je trouve
toujours déplorable que quand on nous
parle de classement des pays qui donnent
le plus les critères ne sont pas tenus
en compte et le fait que certains pays
donnent du matériel et obtiennent une
compensation financière de la part de
l'Union la première chose c'est que
aujourd'hui il y aura au moins quatre et
demi à 5 milliards de dons qui seraient
éligible donc on voit ce fond qui est
prévu je crois 2021-2027 va être vite
épuisée d'autant que ce fond
initialement était là pour financer un
certain nombre d'action en Afrique où la
situation on peut dire qu'il y a un
front ukrainien pour les pays
occidentaux mais il y a aussi un second
front en Afrique avec à la fois les
manipulations l'action de Wagner la
déstabilisation russe et chinoise donc
que va-t-il advenir je sais
qu'actuellement il y a 2,5 milliards de
compensation pour aide
militaire fourni à l'Ukraine qui ont
déjà été engagés mais on a là à la fois
un problème de volume et un problème de
destination est-ce qu'on doit abandonner
l'usage de ce fond de cette facilité
pour l'Afrique la deuxième question
c'est toujours l'éternel question sur la
Chine on a avancé on a avancé un peu la
raison marchande notamment en Allemagne
mais dans d'autres pays l'emporte
toujours sur la réalité croire que la
généralement appartenait dans les
conférences climatiques ou biodiversité
sur le papier c'est vrai dans
l'exécution c'est donc je crois que on
avance mais on avance à pas tellement
raisonnable encore que la vitesse du fil
du canon pose quand même question avant
de considérer véritablement qu'il y a
des mesures plus sérieuses à prendre
notamment en terme d'ingérence et
d'influence dans nos secteurs
stratégiques de la part de la Chine
merci
beaucoup d'abord en réponse à une des
questions que vous m'avez posé monsieur
le président
la présidente de la Commission
européenne Ursula vanderlione pendant la
conférence de la reconstruction à Berlin
le 25 octobre et donc après le Conseil
européen
a effectivement mentionné la poursuite
du soutien à l'Ukraine il faut
distinguer la survie au quotidien des
efforts de reconstruction qui ne sont
pas encore vraiment chiffrés et donc les
efforts de soutien au quotidien ils sont
de trop ils sont estimés entre 3 à 5
milliards ça dépend un peu de la façon
dont ils arrivent à fonctionner et ce
dont ils arrivent à exporter et là
dessus l'Union européenne prévoit de
fournir un virgule 5 milliards d'euros
par mois soit 18 milliards au total pour
le président de la République
a décidé d'organiser dans les prochaines
semaines une conférence internationale
pour la résilience de l'Ukraine à Paris
et dans laquelle ils seront discutés les
modalités d'aide à l'Ukraine
à court terme et notamment comment
continuer sur le plan humanitaire
évidemment je suis à votre disposition
pour plus de détails quand tout nous en
aurons donc plus près de l'échéance
sur sur l'énergie
monsieur le sénateur fabriqué et
Monsieur en fait les trois vous m'avez
tous souligné à quel point cela prend du
temps c'est vrai et ça prend du temps
c'est ça prend plus de temps peut-être
que ce que le covid nous a donné comme
je n'espère pas comme habitude en tous
les cas je comprends tout à fait
l'inquiétude sur le temps alors je vais
je vais répondre deux choses la première
c'est pour ça qu'on fait beaucoup de
choses en national comme je vous le
disais dans l'introduction le bouclier
est arrivé très important à la fois pour
les ménages les entreprises et le
président de la République l'a rappelé
hier soir les collectivités
locales la raison pour laquelle ça prend
du temps au niveau européen c'est qu'il
n'y a pas un pays qui a un mix
énergétique qui ressemble à l'autre nous
dépendons très peu du gaz l'Allemagne et
l'Italie comme vous savez dépendent
beaucoup du gaz et donc il faut arriver
à 27 à se mettre d'accord sur des
mesures qui permettent de
satisfaire les contraintes et de
répondre aux inquiétudes des uns et des
autres si je dis les choses très
simplement le plafond du prix du gaz
fait très peur à certains pays qui ont
peur qu'avec une telle mesure l'Europe
n'arrive plus à se fournir et que le gaz
parte en Asie et en Chine et c'est pour
ça que pour l'instant on parle d'un
plafond glissant en fonction du prix de
marché le découplage que nous demandons
du prix du gaz de l'électricité nous
bénéficient mais coûte cher à d'autres
pays et peut à nous donc il faut qu'on
arrive à trouver en mécanisme qui fait
qu'on puisse en bénéficier mais qu'on ne
fasse pas porter le coût financier à
ceux qui ont eux fournissent beaucoup
qui produisent beaucoup d'électricité
avec le gaz parce qu'en fait c'est quoi
ce mécanisme c'est de subventionner le
prix du gaz donc nous bénéficierions de
la baisse du prix de l'électricité mais
comme nous ne produisons pas beaucoup
d'électricité avec du gaz sans avoir à
payer le codé subventions vous voyez
bien que ça peut pas être satisfaisant
pour tout le monde et c'est vraiment sur
ces détails que l'on est en train de de
discuter
vous m'avez interrogé sur Meetic 4 comme
une entorse
au nom financement des énergies fossiles
alors comme vous l'avez souligné ce
n'est plus médical c'est barman
c'est destiné à transporter de
l'hydrogène de l'hydrogène vert et vous
avez sûrement vu que dans les
communiquer il est bien écrit que la
proportion de gaz serait très limitée et
la raison pour laquelle le président a
voulu troquer j'allais dire barbare
c'est précisément pour ne pas financer
pour ne pas se mettre d'accord sur un
gaz au duc puisque notre objectif est de
décarboner notre héerné énergie et la
condition et la mise en oeuvre de Barma
c'est bien que ce soit l'hydrogène et
l'hydrogène propre avec une
proportionnalité de gaz puisque le gaz
est comme vous le savez dans la taxe de
l'Union européenne une énergie
transition pour une période de
transition
en ce qui concerne le et puis
j'ajouterai là-dessus et il va y avoir
des études de faisabilité bien sûr aussi
de conséquences environnementales et que
c'est
le calendrier et le projet de possible
mise en oeuvre avec une étude de
faisabilité sera probablement
probablement discuté au sommet
Méditerranée qui aura lieu début
décembre entre l'Espagne le Portugal et
la France notamment
donc pour le calendrier pardon pour
revenir aux questions sur l'énergie et
quand je distingue les actions
européennes des actions nationales
il y aura la présidentielle Lady autant
de conseils énergiques que nécessaire
pour faire avancer ses solutions et donc
il y a pour l'instant une date de
rendez-vous du 24 novembre mais s'il
faut le revenir avant ce sera fait avant
je peux vous assurer que les personnes
en charge du corps sur ce sujet et
travaille jour et nuit et week-end et
que il y aura des réunions autant de
besoins
la facilité européenne
de la paix
alors j'ai plusieurs plusieurs petites
remarques ici d'ailleurs les chefs
d'État gouvernement ont décidé de la
mise en oeuvre de la sixième tranche
donc on ne parle de virgule 5 milliards
mais de 3 milliards je crois que ce sera
réétudié en tant que le besoin vous
m'avez
vous m'avez également interrogé sur ce
que font les uns et les autres il n'y a
pas de comparaison publique possible du
soutien qui est apporté à l'Ukraine
c'est comme vous le savez c'est il y a
pas
c'est déclaratifs certains incluent les
coûts de transport
et par ailleurs l'Ukraine a demandé à
beaucoup de pays dont la France de ne
pas tout dévoiler pour ne pas évidemment
donner d'informations à la Russie donc
je crois que la France fait toute sa
part et bien plus que vraiment
pleinement ça parle beaucoup de petits
pays ont vraiment aussi quand on parle
des pays baltes des pays de l'Est qui se
sont particulièrement touchés en
proportion de ce qu'ils ont aussi
effectivement fait plein d'efforts et la
raison pour laquelle on réabonde avec
une sixième tranche se font cette
facilité européenne de la paix monsieur
le présidentateur et précisément à la
fois pour faire face aux besoins de
l'Ukraine et pour faire face aux autres
besoins
si ce que vous soulignez avec raison si
je crois plutôt un retard dû à notre
philosophie
pré agression de l'Ukraine par la Russie
et qui a fait que nous devons maintenant
accélérer surtout ce qui est défense et
sur les projets communs que l'Union
européenne peut avoir en matière de
défense et vous savez que Thierry Breton
a beaucoup fait bouger les choses à la
Commission européenne dans cette faveur
sur toute la chaîne
sur toute la chaîne de défense que ce
soit sur la recherche et le
développement sur les projets
industriels sur les coopérations et on a
la boussole stratégique que l'on va
continuer à mettre en œuvre et également
sur la formation et sur la coopération
des personnes
vous avez également souligné le point de
la Chine et j'ai noté raison notamment
sur l'Allemagne il y a une grosse
discussion comme je vous le disais sur
sur la Chine je crois que ce que tous
les pays il y a deux choses à prendre en
compte d'abord sur sur l'Allemagne
effectivement son modèle est quand même
fortement secoué le chancelier la
reconnaît lui-même en appelant en
immense là en utilisant le mot allemand
c'est un changement de paradigme
colossal pour pour l'Allemagne il faut
il faut s'en rendre compte c'est
l'ombrelle
militaire américaine qui avait été
secouée par par le président Trump pour
que c'était la même chose pour les pays
nordiques d'une part si on fait un autre
triptyque
la deuxième chose c'est la compétitivité
repose en largement sur une énergie pas
chère fournie par la Russie c'est
terminé
et les chaînes et les exportations vers
la Chine et effectivement comme on est
en train de changer le poids relatif des
trois éléments de la stratégie envers la
Chine c'est presque une question
existentielle qui se posait ce modèle
donc on peut on peut comprendre que ça
met du temps de réajuster et de regarder
comment réorienter une dynamique
économique nationale
vous avez pu voir que les discussions
qui ont lieu en Conseil européen ont une
influence puisque là où on avait des
alors il faut toujours faire attention à
la presse mais des reports des
discussions d'investissement de prise
d'investissement de 35% par une
entreprise chinoise dans une activité
allemande c'est descendu à 25% après et
le débat n'est pas fini voilà merci
merci Madame la Ministre alors pierre
Jean-Yves et puis Elsa ensuite
pierre le coup
désolé
oui trois questions très rapide la
première il y a un accord qui avait été
passé sous hésite de l'ONU sur la
question alimentaire pour évacuer les
stocks de céréales du crâne cet accord
il arrive à échéance fin novembre
qu'est-ce qui est-ce que des choses sont
envisagées pour la suite sur cette
question alimentaire
alors je ne sais pas donc une mesure
l'Ukraine on va continuer ou pas à
produire des céréales mais pour les pays
destinataires notamment les pays du Sud
pour lesquels la question alimentaire
est une question d'urgence
qu'est-ce qui va se passer
dans l'année à venir est-ce que sur
cette question il y a des choses qui ont
été discutées et envisagées soit pour
prolonger l'accord
avec l'Ukraine avec la cour des Russes
dans la négociation qui avait été
conduite soit pour envisager d'autres
d'autres solutions deuxièmement sur la
question électricité bon je remets une
couche mais sur la question de l'énergie
ce que vous nous dites n'est pas
vraiment de nature à nous rassurer parce
que on a l'impression que la question de
la décorrélation
le prix du gaz électricité
n'a pas de perspective d'aboutir dans ce
qu'on entend dans l'année dans l'année
qui vient
et donc on a du mal à voir où sont les
perspectives de baisse du prix
chez nous dans les négociations
actuelles concrètement
et
j'ai une question à ce propos vous dites
que ceux qui craignent
de cette décorrélation parce que elle
risquerait
les prix du gaz de
que le gaz partent vers l'Asie etc
quels sont les producteurs
qui font
peser ce risque
c'est à dire qu'ils envisagerait
qu'est-ce qui permet de
dire ça et dernière remarque sur ça
c'est que dans ce contexte de
nos accords global
l'accord sur l'achat conjoint de gaz
peut avoir un effet très pervers
parce que il peut faire pression sur les
prix mais il peut aussi nous rendre
dépendant
sur cette question d'une logique qui
n'est pas la nôtre
celle de renforcer notre dépendance au
gaz
et puis
une troisième très courte question c'est
sur la COP 27 vous avez dit que l'Union
européenne s'est fixé un monde à plus
ambitieux
compte tenu de notre situation
énergétique
quel est ces quels sont ses objectifs
plus ambitieux parce que je vois mal
l'Union européenne dans les conditions
actuelles
donner beaucoup de leçons au monde
entier sur la question de la transition
énergétique
vu ça dépendances révélée au gaz et
est-ce qu'il y a des objectifs plus
ambitieux notamment en matière de
financement de la transition pour les
pays qui ont besoin de financement pour
assurer cette transition notamment dans
le sud
merci Pierre Jean-Yves Lecomte
le Président vous avez évoqué
du modèle allemand d'ailleurs quand on
les remarques que José Boré a fait il y
a une semaine en fait il les
appliquaient
ils pensaient peut-être Allemagne mais
ils disent à Europe en fait il a dit on
a vécu avec le parapluie américain
le business avec la Chine l'énergie
l'énergie russe
c'est une remise en cause complète et
[Musique]
nous tant les citoyens européens que
finalement autour de l'Europe on perçoit
bien que c'est effectivement mon très
grandes fragilité pour l'Union
européenne sur ce sur ce point alors
c'est vrai que c'est d'abord le modèle
allemand mais pas que parce que autour
de finalement l'économie l'ensemble de
l'économie de l'Union européenne a
bénéficier par capillarité de de du
modèle du modèle allemand de la même
manière bon pas simplement se contenter
de dire que on a l'inflation la plus
faible de l'Union européenne le problème
de l'inflation dans l'Union européenne
mais aussi autour quand on voit les pays
du Sud ou quand on voit la Turquie
sont aussi un problème dans nos
relations avec ces pays dans la
situation sociale et économique qui est
vécu dans ces pays il y a un certain
nombre de négociations avec les pays du
FMI dans la plupart des pays d'Afrique
Nord compte tenu de l'aggravation de de
ces situations comment est-ce que
l'Union européenne peut essayer
d'accompagner ces difficultés qui sont à
court terme encore plus gênante pour la
stabilité que ce que nous avons dans
l'Union européenne deuxièmement quand on
vous l'avez évoqué les conclusions sur
les questions énergétiques bon on va
continuer à travailler oui quand on voit
les conclusions elles sont finalement
assez laborieuses donc pourquoi on a des
points de départ très très très très
très différent
depuis 10 jours
les divergences franco-allemandes sur un
énorme sujet mais en particulier sur ces
sujets se font toujours je pense aussi à
la question de de l'hydrogène
quel est le plan pour rétablir une
relation avec l'Allemagne qui permet
finalement d'entraider le reste d'Union
Européenne en fait on oublie toujours
c'est pas que la France et l'Allemagne
se mettre d'accord et impose aux autres
c'est qu'une fois que la France et
l'Allemagne se mettent d'accord on est
tellement différent finalement on est
capable d'entraîner les autres sur le
point
nos points d'arrivée alors quel est le
plan parce que s'il y a pas de contre la
France et l'Allemagne si on n'arrive pas
à s'équilibrer sur les questions les
questions de gazoduc ou de de transfert
de manière de voir sur les questions en
particulier énergétiques et aussi sur
l'hydrogène ça va être difficile alors
quel est le planning pour rétablir sur
ces sujets mais aussi sur les questions
de défense
une capacité franco-allemande
d'initiative qui aura aussi besoin de
conv sur les autres qui voient bien que
notre modèle est mise en cause mais il
faut quand même qu'on arrive à se mettre
d'accord si Jean-Yves Elsa chalk
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre alors je me permets de vous
transmettre une question de notre
collègue Véronique Guillotin sénatrice
de Meurthe-et-Moselle qui n'a pas pu
être présent de ce matin et qui
souhaitait vous poser cette question
concernant alors moi le Conseil européen
mais une question tout aussi importante
sur l'épidémie de covid on sait qu'il a
permis de faire émerger certains points
importants d'une part que les citoyens
ont été sensibilisés à l'importance de
la vaccination en tant qu'outil majeur
de lutte contre certaines maladies que
les citoyens ont dans leur grande
majorité compris la valeur d'un schéma
vaccinal complet et que également les
infrastructures qui ont été mises en
place pour le certificat covid ont
permis de valider le cadre de confiance
au niveau européen ces acquis qui
doivent maintenant être utilisés à bon
escient au niveau européen
doivent pouvoir se faire et en cela une
démarche volontaire pourrait être promu
auprès des instances européennes
notamment par la France pour permettre
le déploiement d'une carte de
vaccination du citoyen européen et comme
vous le savez la grande région dans
laquelle 4 pays sont représentés et qui
est en ce moment présidé par Jean rotner
au titre de la région Grand Est exprimé
d'ores et déjà son souhait d'être
territoire d'expérimentation de cette
carte de vaccination et donc ma question
est la question de ma collègue Véronique
Guillotin est simple pouvez-vous nous
préciser quelle est la position de la
France sur ce sujet et si des avancées
sont attendues je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
monsieur le sénateur Laurent vous m'avez
interrogé sur la question alimentaire et
les stocks de céréales effectivement le
Conseil européen a pardon
pardon
à traiter de ce sujet comme comme je le
disais
il a parlé de la nécessité du
renforcement des corridors de solidarité
qui ont déjà permis de faire sortir du
crâne plus de 10 millions de tonnes de
céréales il a fait également fait appel
à renouveler l'accord qui est sous
l'égide de l'ONU et qui s'achève en
novembre
et je crois que ça a toujours été dans
les intentions
du président de continuer à pousser les
pays en ce sens si c'était le sens de
l'initiative farm qui avait été portée
avant plutôt dans la crise et aussi en
lien avec l'Union africaine de vraiment
faire que ce soit soutenable et durable
dans le temps
ensuite vous m'avez posé la question
d'aller décorrélations je crois que
c'est depuis février ou mars dernier que
le gouvernement français pousse
une décorrélation sur le court terme
entre les prix du gaz et ceux
d'électricité et une réforme du marché
de l'électricité plus pérenne nous
continuons dans les cons dans les
conclusions du Conseil européen
effectivement les chefs d'État et de
gouvernement ont demandé à la Commission
de faire des propositions en ce sens et
sur les deux sujets et la Commission
s'est engagée par la réforme plus
pérenne en janvier 2023
je crois que ce qu'il est important de
dire ici ce n'est pas parce que nous
avons des difficultés de d'adaptation à
court terme et c'est pour ça qu'en
national on a un gros bouclier pour
protéger les personnes et nos citoyens
nos concitoyens en attendant d'avoir
assisté plus pérenne et plus de moyen
terme qu'il faut jeter le bébé avec
l'eau du vin ce marché unique de
l'énergie qui permet des énergies mixes
différents nous assurent une grande
solidarité en cas de problème je
rappelle que nous importons de
l'électricité depuis le début de l'été
donc certes nous devons adapter le
système de prix nous devons en échange
fournir du gaz à l'Allemagne quand elle
en manque mais je crois que nous devons
aussi être reconnaissants que toutes ces
interconnexions existent et nous
permettent d'emporter de l'électricité
de nos voisins
vous m'avez aussi interrogé sur les
producteurs qui pourraient décider de
vendre du gaz à d'autres pays il y a une
compétition mondiale pour le gaz naturel
liquéfié et effectivement la pression
sur le gaz naturel qui est à augmenter
puisque les gazoducs comme vous le savez
la Russie a décidé de ne plus les
utiliser je vais dire pudiquement
il y a eu un accord des chefs d'État et
de gouvernement pour que la Commission
soit mandatée aille négocier avec la
Norvège mais également entre chefs
d'État et gouvernement pour s'allier
avec les États-Unis et la Corée pour
aller discuter du prix du gaz également
avec nos alliés américains
mais tout ça est la raison pour laquelle
on ces discussions se font également
avec le Japon et la Corée c'est parce
que l'objectif c'est évidemment de ne
pas faire augmenter les prix mais
d'arriver à aller faire des pressiers de
ne pas faire de concurrence entre nous à
la fois au niveau européen et au niveau
international ce qui permettra d'enlever
un peu de pression de demande sur
l'offre et donc de ramener les prix à la
baisse je voudrais répéter ici
aujourd'hui que la meilleure façon de
faire baisser les prix c'est de faire
baisser la demande à court terme et donc
d'être très économe avec l'utilisation
de notre gaz
et en termes de cop27 le mandat plus
ambitieux est à l'étude bien sûr
vous arguments sont tout à fait entendus
l'idée est plutôt d'accès à ce stade
l'idée plutôt d'accélérer le
renouvelable et le financement de
l'adaptation parce qu'on a beaucoup
travaillé sur la thémation mais je crois
que on peut faire plus sur l'adaptation
cette fois monsieur le sénateur le
compte vous m'avez donc votre question
portait essentiellement sur le couple
franco-allemand et on peut dire ça et la
question de l'hydrogène notamment
je crois qu'il est important d'avoir en
tête que oui nous sommes dans un
changement de paradigme qui est mondial
et que le couple franco-allemand
s'adapte à ce changement de notamment je
vais les répéter mais le Conseil des
ministres franco-allemande n'a pas été
annulé il a été reporté et la raison
pour laquelle il a été reporté c'est
pour vous répondre c'est précisément
pour travailler de façon plus concrète
un cahier des charges
entre les ministres en ce qui concerne
la défense le spatial l'énergie la
culture l'éducation
la réforme du gouvernance économique de
l'Europe l'idée est vraiment d'arriver à
un conseil des ministres franco-allemand
qui en bon français des livres et permet
effectivement d'accélérer la feuille de
route de l'Union européenne je suis
complètement d'accord avec vous
ce qu'on a ce qu'on appelle le groupe
franco-allemand et parfois un irritant
pour d'autres pays de l'Union européenne
parce que ce moteur qui s'impose mais à
l'inverse il y a de l'inquiétude parmi
nos amis européens quand il y a ce
sentiment que le moteur franco-allemand
n'avance pas assez vite parce qu'il
permet effectivement de réconcilier des
positions qui sont différentes donc il
est là il est plus compliqué parce que
la situation énergétique est compliquée
mais justement l'idée avec le déjeuner
entre le président et le chancelier hier
était de faire un état des lieux de ce
sur quoi on pouvait avancer et accélérer
en commun et vous avez lu les rapports
de presse et effectivement
nous avons
[Musique]
sur l'hydrogène je crois qu'il faut il
faut avoir deux choses en tête la
prochaine la première pardon c'est
comment on fait de l'hydrogène vert et
c'est vrai qu'il y a énormément de
recherches et développement et qu'on le
voit beaucoup en ce moment
avec le soleil avec le vent avec avec
l'hydroélectrique il y a une question
qui se pose sur l'hydrogène qui est
celle de son transport
certains industriels expliquent aussi
facile d'autres il y a beaucoup de
déperditions et ça c'est un des sujets
par exemple sur lesquels on voudrait se
pencher ensemble pour essayer de mieux
comprendre ce qui peut être fait
notamment dans le cadre de barquette que
vous mentionnez tout à l'heure voilà moi
ce que je voudrais dire en conclusion
sur le coup franco-allemand c'est que il
se parle ils établissent
il se parlait il se passe sur différents
sujets l'idée c'est d'être concrète
d'avancer à la fonction sur la
compréhension des choses et ensuite
d'embarquer l'Union européenne comme ça
a toujours été le cas
en ce qui concerne
le déploiement d'une carte de
vaccination européenne effectivement
il y a vous avez fait il y a beaucoup de
travaux qui ont été faits par la
symétrie
que vous avez mentionné notamment sur
les thématiques de santé il y a aussi un
rapport d'information dessinatrice
gruyère sur la stratégie pharmaceutique
qui était présenté le 20 octobre dernier
mais sur le sujet pris spécifique de la
proposition d'une carte de vaccination
du citoyen européen la Commission
européenne pourrait effectivement
examiner la faisabilité de l'élaboration
d'une telle carte pour tous les citoyens
de l'Union européenne et nous sommes
favorables à l'étude de cette initiative
ce qui pourrait être fait c'est par
exemple une étude de faisabilité ou
pilote dans de certaines régions d'Union
Européenne et nous sommes tout à fait
pour que la grande région soit
volontaire pour expérimenter ce
dispositif s'il venait à être mis en
ordre
la présidentielle du Conseil de l'Union
européenne organise les 21 et 22
novembre à Prague une réunion d'experts
sur la vaccination et au cours de cette
réunion et d'experts cette proposition
pour être évoquée je vous propose que
nous en reparlions après
merci
allemande j'avais vu la situation de des
pays d'Afrique du Nord
on sent que c'est plus en plus dur
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour
accompagner ces situations où il y a des
programmes éphémis qui sont en
négociation mais je vois vous avez que
je suis assez inquiet sur l'évolution
économique de toute nos voisins
pardon effectivement excusez-moi de pas
avoir répondu à cette question j'imagine
que vous mentionnez pas la Turquie qui
ne se sent pas inquiète à ce stade donc
mais plutôt les autres pays
d'Afrique du Nord et
j'ai dit qu'il ne se sent pas inquiète à
ce stade
elle est sur sur les autres pays
d'Afrique du Nord c'est pour ça que le
il y a deux choses il y a d'abord
l'action européenne qui est directement
liée aux tensions sur les céréales et
sur laquelle effectivement nous voulons
accélérer et à nouveau j'ai mentionné
l'initiative précisément pour ça donc
une accélération là-dessus le FMI
effectivement et s'inquiète de la
situation et de beaucoup de pays
émergents et en développement à la fois
à cause des silencieux sur les céréales
et aussi de la remontée des taux
d'intérêt comme vous savez dans
l'ensemble du monde qui évidemment font
peser pèse plus particulièrement sur les
pays qui sont endettés et qui aussi plus
de mal à attirer des capitaux dans un
contexte de remontée de taux d'intérêt à
ce stade que je peux vous dire c'est que
nous suivons nous suivons avec beaucoup
d'attention et que la France est
toujours très impliquée à la fois au FMI
où elle était présente avec plusieurs
ministres pour les rencontres annuels il
y a 15 jours qui ma mémoire est bonne
et
également à travers le Club de Paris et
si vous pensez à quelque chose de plus
particulier je suis
à votre disposition pour en parler en
bilatérale
suivante
Colette Patricia et Christine
du Conseil européen je suis moi aussi
préoccupé par la relation
franco-allemande mais vous venez de
répondre à mon collègue et mes questions
quand même pour dire que il y a ressenti
peut-être au niveau médiatique
sur les divergence qui ont l'air de se
multiplier entre les deux pays et
l'annulation du Conseil des ministres et
de dire qu'il y avait un changement
de parisien et que le Conseil avait été
reporté mais bon je crois que ce n'est
pas quand même entendu par les
personnes qui s'intéressent au couple
allemand pour observer depuis de
nombreuses années la vision politique
européenne des deux pays je
j'ai confiance mais je crois qu'il faut
quand même être vigilant sur
certains changements voilà vous l'avez
dit le centième anniversaire du Traité
de l'Elysée pourra réactiver
je l'espère en tout cas et les liens
culturels éducatifs entre la France et
l'Allemagne
il faut il faut y aller
d'observation merci
madame la ministre lors du dernier
Conseil européen les 27 ans
collectivement condamnés les actes de
sabotage comme il contre le gaz du CAN
de North stream vous le savez la guerre
d'agression livrée par la Russie à
l'Ukraine à engendré de nouveaux risques
notamment les attaques physiques et
sidaires attaques qui se combine souvent
pour former une menace hybride le
Conseil a d'ailleurs invité les États
membres à prendre des mesures de
coopération urgentes et efficaces avec
la Commission en vue de renforcer la
résilience des infrastructures critiques
et notamment les infrastructures
transfrontalières aussi madame la
ministre quels sont les pistes
envisagées par la France pour protéger
nos infrastructures élus d'une région
transfrontalière ce sujet nous
interpelle fortement je vous remercie
oui merci à Monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre la le contexte énergétique
actuel oblige les entreprises à repenser
leur procédure d'approvisionnement voire
même à envisager de délocaliser leur
site de production par exemple aux
États-Unis où l'énergie est plus
abondante comment l'Union européenne et
le Conseil vont-ils concilier ce besoin
de
compétitivité de l'Union européenne avec
un certain nombre de textes qui sont en
cours de discussion et je pense ici à la
directive sur le devoir de vigilance sur
lequel notre commission a fait un
certain nombre de remarques parce que ce
texte impose notamment aux entreprises
européennes de maîtriser sur l'ensemble
de leur chaîne de valeur le respect d'un
certain nombre de conditions et
notamment les conditions d'extraction
des matières premières donc à partir du
moment où les entreprises vont commencer
à s'approvisionner par par exemple en
gaz américain que le sourcing on sait la
zone de provenance mais on ne connaît
pas forcément les conditions
d'extraction quand on achète auprès d'un
trader comment allez-vous concilier ces
impératifs tout en essayant de maintenir
la compétitivité de notre industrie
merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre
le 29 juillet dernier je vous écrivais
bien sûr pour vous féliciter et je vous
renouvelle mais félicitations mes vœux
de réussite à la tête de ce ministère je
vous écrivais également pour vous
interroger pour connaître les actions
que vous entendiez pour nous en faveur
d'un écosystème français et européen du
cloud donc des technologies importantes
aujourd'hui en tout cas incontournable
pour porter nos projets nationaux et
européen
sachant que à l'heure actuelle il n'y a
plus aucun cadre de protection de
transfert des données des Européens vers
les États-Unis
nous sommes sur la jurisprudence 2 après
la validation du plan et le sushield et
en l'état
même si nous travaillons à des textes
européens tels que le Data Act pour
créer un cadre sécurisé de protection
des données européennes il n'en demeure
pas moins qu'il y a une politique
industrielle amené et je ne vois pas
d'autres solutions que que celle-ci
plutôt que d'avoir recours aux
technologies
extra-européenne on est toujours sur le
coup des lois extraites territoriales
américaines et ça c'est une donnée dont
on ne peut pas
se passer vous avez bien voulu me
répondre
d'ailleurs hier mais j'ai pas de
précision par rapport à cette volonté de
la mise en oeuvre d'une politique
industrielle donc je voudrais savoir
voilà quels sont les intentions du
Gouvernement et vos intentions dans la
perspective notamment aussi du projet de
plateforme des données de santé des
Européens qui devrai vous appuyer sur le
modèle français or le modèle français à
l'heure actuelle comme vous le savez il
est suspendu il était confié à Microsoft
azur et la demande d'habilitation latine
a été suspendue car ce projet soulève
des problèmes quant à la protection
précisément vu le contexte des données
de santé des Français je vous remercie
madame la ministre
merci merci à vous tous
alors madame la chinatrice mélo
merci d'avoir reposé la question ce qui
va me permettre de faire quelques
précisions je voudrais vraiment
souligner qu'il y a de bonnes relations
de travail le déjeuner entre le
président et le chancelier c'est
vraiment bien passé hier et il y a de
bonnes relations de travail entre les
différents ministres également comme
vous savez il y a eu un conseil définit
des ministres de l'économie la semaine
dernière je parle régulièrement à
j'allais dire tous mes homologues parce
qu'en fait comme nous fonctionnait un
peu différemment effectivement mon
homologue officiel et les autres sur les
sujets en particulier le ministre de
l'Éducation français travaille très bien
avec le ministre de l'Éducation allemand
nous comptons aussi sur les groupes
d'amitié parlementaires c'est vraiment
très important pour soutenir les bonnes
relations des deux pays à nouveau
le report du cmfa vraiment la volonté de
faire un conseil des ministres de
substance et pas de pas de forme comme
vous le comme vous le savez
madame
sur les infrastructures
critique
oui la production la protection pardon
de nos infrastructures critiques et
notamment en manière énergétique mais
pas seulement et essentiel et c'est
vraiment l'actualité le montre et c'est
pour ça que le Conseil européen c'est
c'est
a beaucoup travaillé dessus la France et
l'Union européenne tous ensemble
agissent depuis longtemps pour renforcer
la production et la résilience de ces
infrastructures je crois qu'on a tous
beaucoup entendu parler du sujet qui
voulait pas dire grand-chose jusqu'à ce
que un hors stream arrive
mais sous la présidence française de
l'Union européenne il y a eu un accord
entre le Conseil et le Parlement sur la
directive sécurité des réseaux et des
systèmes d'information c'est la Corée
NS2 et toujours sur la présidence
française de l'Union européenne un autre
accord a été trouvé sur la directive de
résilience des entités critiques donc
avec ces deux textes l'Union européenne
peut renforcer la sécurité de ces
infrastructures puisque c'est bien au
niveau de l'Union européenne qu'il faut
agir comme vous le savez et à nouveau la
France prendra toutes les mesures
nationales qui seront nécessaires pour
s'inscrire dans ce cadre et protéger la
résilience de nos infrastructures
énergétique et elle était communication
évidemment
juste en continuité serait-il possible
d'avoir des exercices de terrain avec
nos élus avec nos partenaires
transfrontaliers ça se faisait une
époque sur sur d'autres problématiques
mais peut-être
très vraiment intéressant d'avoir
vraiment un COPIL j'allais dire de
travail
entre moi je suis à l'Allemagne et la
Suisse mais dans d'autres qui ont aussi
d'autres pays voisins peut-être dans le
futur d'avoir au moins cette relation
pour pouvoir le cas échéant bien
communiquer avec le préfet
c'est une excellente suggestion beaucoup
d'institutions font ce genre de
d'exercice de gestion de crise mais je
vous reviendrai mais on va regarder
maintenant vous avez vous avez raison si
période actuelle ça peut être un sujet
ça peut être vraiment très utile je vous
reviens sur sur le sujet
madame la signatrice l'avare si vous
m'avez parlé de des locations aux
États-Unis et du problème de
compétitivité je crois que vous avez
raison le la période actuelle pose des
sujets de compétitivité de deux ordres
d'une part le prix d'énergie et d'autre
part le inflation réduction actes que
les États-Unis ont mis en place et qui
en gros subventionne la production
automobile aux États-Unis de voitures
américaine
il y a deux choses que je voudrais dire
à ce sujet sur l'énergie et sur les prix
vraiment nous travaillons d'arrache qui
est à faire baisser ses prix et à
protéger les énergies pour éviter ce
type de délocalisation j'ai bien
conscience qu'on commence à en voir et
c'est quelque chose qui nous inquiète et
c'est pour ça que la France met autant
de pression
fait autant d'efforts à la fois sur ce
territoire et mais autant de pression au
niveau du territoire européen pour
éviter ce genre de situation sur les
flèche
qui est vraiment une mesure pour le coup
destiné à
à favoriser la protection la production
aux US et la compétitivité des
entreprises qui vont s'installer aux
États-Unis là aussi la l'Union
européenne est en train de réagir là
aussi c'est un sujet de discussion très
convergent avec l'Allemagne et vous avez
pu en avoir un aperçu hier soir lorsque
le président de la République
a suggéré qu'il allait réserver des
aides notamment automobile aux achats
européens
et de voitures européennes et par
ailleurs je crois qu'il est il serait
juste de dire que sous la présidence
française de l'Union européenne et pas
que sous la présidence française de
l'Union européenne la France pousse
toujours pour la préférence européenne
que ce soit dans l'industrie
j'allais dire courantes ou en matière de
défense ou même ou même d'espace
ce qui me fait une transition avec la
question de la sénatrice morale de
saillie sur le cloud
en ce qui concerne la protection
de transfert de données vous avez raison
que c'est en cours de
réactualisation notamment suite au
récentes annonces qui ont été faits sur
la réforme du système judiciaire
américain qui pour nous marque vraiment
le franchissement d'une nouvelle étape
dans le renforcement du cadre de
protection et des données européennes
qui vont être traitées par les acteurs
américains donc la Commission européenne
devrait examiner très prochainement une
nouvelle mesure
nous allons être associés à l'examen de
ces mesures et nous évidemment faut
prendre des fonds pardon preuve de la
plus grande vigilance pour pour assurer
le plus haut niveau de protection
possible des droits fondamentaux de nos
citoyens et en particulier vous avez
fait le lien avec l'éventualité d'une
politique industrielle à mener je crois
que quand on
quand on parle du changement de
paradigme c'est à la fois ce que je vous
disais plutôt sur les États-Unis la
Chine et le rôle de la Chine mais c'est
également en matière de politique
industrielle alors avant c'est une
expression très française la politique
industrielle mais maintenant ça devient
une
expression tout à fait européenne
pour s'occuper en fait de toute la
résilience de la chaîne de production
que ce soit le sourcing en beau français
de matériaux critiques le développement
de nos technologies notamment avec le
TIPS actes donc la protection de nos
technologies à l'export mais aussi dans
les investissements directs étrangers
qui sont faits chez nous et donc à
nouveau sur toute cette chaîne il y a
une attention particulière de l'Union
européenne et puis des actes avec les
différentes mesures que je viens de
mentionner me poser la question de la
volonté non seulement la volonté là mais
elle se traduit par des actes de façon
assez syst
et puis vous m'avez interrogé plus
précisément sur l'espace européen des
données de santé
et évidemment la protection et la
préservation de l'intégrité de ces
données est très importante pour nous
donc là ce que nous sommes en train de
faire c'est d'abord émerger un cadre
robuste pour la protection des données
et la lutte contre l'application
extra-territoriale de loi étrangères qui
est précisément ce à quoi vous faisiez
attention donc on est en train de
renforcer l'encadrement du transfert de
données vers les pays tiers il y a eu
une jurisprudence de la Cour de justice
de l'Union européenne
au sein de la loi sur la gouvernance des
données c'est le détail gouvernance acte
et celui-ci a été publié celle-ci a été
publiée pardon au Journal officiel de
l'Union européenne
au premier semestre 2022
nous déployons maintenant des efforts
identiques dans le cadre de négociations
en cours sur la loi sur les données
c'est le delta Act et le règlement
relatif à la création d'espaces
européens des données de santé
voilà je vois à votre
[Musique]
langage corporel que vous n'êtes pas
tout à fait satisfaite je vous écoute
pour la suite de la question
nous avons
travaillé au sein de la commission plan
d'action 2030 la boussole numérique et
nous avons constaté notre apport que la
politique industrielle est encore pas
tout à fait au rendez-vous c'est à dire
que l'ambition reste assez mesurée et
surtout les modalités et les modes de
financement ne sont pas énoncés dans ce
plan d'action des modalités comment on
arrive à créer un écosystème européen du
Cloud pour préserver justement les
données des Européens en l'état donc
c'était comment allez-vous aiguillonner
cette politique pour faire en sorte que
on aille plus loin et qu'on fasse mieux
et qu'on prenne des discussions
législatives pour assurer une forme de
préférence aussi nos propres entreprises
pour sécuriser le système voilà ma
question était plus pratique on va
éviter les textes je les connais c'est
ce qui est fait pour renforcer la
production des données mais qui nous
manque une politique industrielle très
incisive voilà ce que je voulais
connaître de votre part merci Madame la
Ministre d'être attentive à nos
questions je vous imprime madame la
chaîne est triste je c'est un plaisir et
je suis là pour ça
sur les modèles étaient d'abord merci
pour le rapport j'aurais dû j'espère que
je l'ai mentionné tout à l'heure ici ce
n'est pas le cas j'aurais dû le faire
sur les modalités le mode de financement
et c'est évidemment en cours le
commissaire Thierry Breton est très
attentif à ce sujet
quand on parle de Cloud ce sont aussi
des choses dans nos discutons dans les
traités à la fois avec l'Allemagne et
par exemple qui peut qui est dans le sur
lequel nous pourrons aussi intervenir
avec le traité du quérinal puisque c'est
un des axes fort de spatial et le Cloud
comme la défense sur lequel nous voulons
renforcer nos travaux avec l'Italie et
effectivement je n'ai pas de calendrier
à vous fournir là tout de suite
maintenant mais c'est bien évidemment
vraiment quelque chose qui nous suivons
et moi je peux vous en plus se voir en
bilatérale pour en discuter plus en
avant car je crois que vous avez une
autre réunion à 10 heures
merci de votre participation alors c'est
pas qu'on a une autre réunion de la
commission mais on a dans le format
cosaque mais je propose au commissaire
qui restait on a un commissaire
ça peut être intéressant pour certains
d'entre vous et comment on est en visio
la loi sur la liberté des médias c'est
important absolument l'État de droit est
un
des sujets les plus intéressants dans le
contexte actuel merci on sait que les
sujets sont importants l'actualité bouge
donc on sera peut-être amené à vous
revoir rapidement
merci monsieur le Président merci à tous
et à toutes